previously on surgeon simulator let's
give a mulligan on that one and see if
we can go about this correct way sorry
about that Bob you feeling better now
you feeling better Bob hello you all
know bob is a good friend of mine and he
only he would trust me with his life
like this because he knows the quality
doctor that I am I'm just gonna grab one
of these needles here and jab it right
into the patient's face doctor I think
iswhat's we operated his heart
shut up nurse I'm a doctor of course I
know what's best this all right we feel
pretty good if I'm pretty good I mean
pretty badly what have I got I don't
even know what I got there we go ripped
a rib out just like I'm supposed to just
like daddy Tommy daddy he never thought
that I could be a doctor he never
thought I could be a doctor doc don't
you think you should focus on the page
shut up nurse shut up I just ripped out
his long don't think I won't do the same
to you
what is this it's a giant bag of bile in
here well that can't be good for the
patient come on Bob this was an
adventure end of madness that I had not
foreseen my hands aren't what they used
to be I suppose I must end my career
here thank you all so much for watching
I'm sorry Bob I couldn't save you
yeah anyway I'd like to seek my nurse
thank you shut up nurse I know at first
I'd like to thank all of you for
watching and learning from this so
please take this as a lesson if you
trust me with your life you made a bad
decision oh I'm uh I'm operating on Bob
this should go well so let's take a look
at this patient okay good um nurse
twenty-seven cc's of Hydra morgue of
Florence Marvin please